[Music]
a las vegas businessman is plopping down
a million dollars to find out if there
is evidence of an afterlife space
entrepreneur robert bigelow has
announced the creation of a new
institute
that is devoted to research into whether
human consciousness survives
physical death he gave his first and
only on-camera interview
to the i-team's george knapp
this is a life-size full-scale mock-up
bigelow aerospace's sprawling plant is
idle for now
shut down is non-essential during the
early weeks of the covet pandemic
but owner and founder robert bigelow
hopes that his plans to build inflatable
habitats for use in future space
stations
could be revived in the meantime bigelow
is pursuing his twin passions
what he calls the two holy grail
questions of human existence
are we alone in the universe and what
happens to us when we die
he decided at a young age to make enough
money so he could go after the answers
and then i committed when i was about 12
years old
to really get into this someday when i
grew up and i
if i had money and trying to figure a
way how to make money
in order to commune with other people
maybe create
some kind of groups or whatever to help
me
explore bigelow has been funding ufo
research for more than 30 years and has
likely spent more on that mystery than
any person
in history including his purchase of a
paranormal hot spot in utah
known as skinwalker ranch he admits his
interest in the afterlife
is in part motivated by heartbreaking
losses in his own life
his father son grandson and more
recently his wife diane
through the use of mediums bigelow said
he was able to get some level of
assurance
that something in us survives physical
death yeah you have this dichotomy
between the brain and mind right the
brain is the physical manifestation
and the parochial thinking is that when
the brain ceases to function
[Music]
you don't have a mind that's it there is
no consciousness
and so we know by a number of different
ways
that the brain can cease functioning
but your mind can continue well then
where the hell is your mind
hey you've lost your mind right so
where is it last june bigelow developed
a plan to create
bix the bigelow institute for
consciousness studies
the first project for bix is an essay
contest
inviting scholars investigators even
laymen to apply to the bix website to
enter the contest seeking the best
evidence in support of an afterlife
first prize for the contest five hundred
thousand dollars with three hundred
thousand dollars for second place
and a hundred fifty thousand per third
the rules and procedures are listed on
the bix website
bigelow rarely does on-camera interviews
but he gave us the first in which he
answered other questions related to his
ufo projects
he also spoke with the new york times
which has published a remarkable profile
piece
bigelow hopes the news coverage will
result in waves of high quality essays
to help document whether an afterlife is
more than wishful thinking
i think because i believe the other side
does exist that and there's benefits if
people because i've experienced those
with with people
passing over and most people
of any age you know have people that
they lose
so if if you can
if people can be helped um
in a grief situation in a sorrow
situation
by by information
then any information
isn't something that hurts it hurts you
it's a it's a good it's a good
um it's a good gift to have
that information george knapp 8 news now
to hear more of our interview with
robert bigelow check out mysterywire.com
also there are links to the
mix website with information about that
essay contest